[Music]
Mikey Jenny is back with us today to
discuss the prevalence of gnosticism in
all forms of media gnosticism is a
second century belief system that turns
judeo-christian Doctrine and its beliefs
upside down a world viw in which Jesus
is the enemy and Satan is the savior
have you been Enchanted by such Doctrine
let's find out welcome back brother
Mikey thank you for having me again for
those of us that miss the first episode
that you were on catch us up so it's
basically my testimony and how powerful
the media is to influence me as being a
young Christian Child to being enticed
by the occult and Witchcraft and things
like that so media is very powerful and
we know that this is something that
happened to you when you were a teenager
yes do you think it's still prevalent
now oh even more so yeah the the media
is just over time it's like the frog in
the kettle you know we started out with
things like leave at the beaver and it
seemed all good but now we're at a point
where we're entertaining ourselves with
a show is called Lucifer yeah well we
talked about it being predominantly or
at least in the last episode a visual
format but do you think it's in other
forms uh yeah it's in video games kids
movies TV shows basically Satan has
found a powerful tool and he wants to
get his gospel message in all forms of
media from all age ranges so let's get
into it let's dig right in tell me about
nosism and how you found it in media so
gnosticism it's basically an inversion
of Christianity where Lucifer was an
angel that came into the garden and told
Adam and Eve look God's trying to keep
you from having knowledge he doesn't
want you to be smart he doesn't want you
to eat that fruit because you'll be wise
like him and so they it's a luciferian
Doctrine they believe that he was a good
Angel freeing Adam and Eve from this
tyrannical God that put him in this
Garden prison and so that's the way they
believe and when you know what to look
for and you see this template you'll see
it in all forms of media when you taste
of this fruit right you'll know whether
it's from God or from Satan and if it
goes against the word of Christ we know
it's from Satan that's right we have to
test everything according to scripture
test all the spirits right so I think
the misconception with media it affects
us all you know as a Christian we're
like look I don't drink smoke cuss
fornicate all these things but media
impacts us all even when you're pumping
gas at a gas station there's a a TV in
your face and so the big push back is
well I know the difference in reality
and fiction I know that this is you know
fairy tale it doesn't affect me is what
they say but secular sources and
everybody knows that media is powerful
that's why uh you know corporations will
spend a billion dollars on a 60c or not
even 60 seconds 10c ad because they're
going to get the money back that's right
we had Dr Walsh here and he actually
brought that out as well that it's we're
not just dealing with entertainment
we're dealing with something that
happens chemically to us when we're
watching TV it actually puts us in a
Trans State bypasses the frontal lobe
and allows direct access to what helps
us govern ourselves that's exactly right
you know Satan's after our mind that's
what it's all about and if he can get in
there any way he can that's his you know
he's he's getting one over on us so I
think a lot of people you know when we
put up these guards like oh it's just
entertainment we're really allowing the
enemy to to deceive us but we wrestle
not against flesh and blood that's what
Ephesians 6:12 says and um actually 2
Corinthians 10: 4-5 talks about pulling
down the strongholds and casting down
imaginations and bringing into captivity
every thought to The Obedience of Christ
so things we think about are important
our imagination is actually really key
in this right in Genesis it tells us
that men's imaginations were Wicked and
that's why the Earth had to be cleansed
of its sin so here we are again right
and the Lord says that when he returns
it'll be like the time of lot right yeah
are we here yeah and people are
defending it saying well it's just you
you know using your imagination but
that's where sin starts you know Jesus
said to look upon a woman to lust after
her is the same as committing adultery
and even science is backing this stuff
up when when you watch things when you
observe things your brain fires the same
way as if as if you're doing it yourself
so I have a couple examples here but I
want to talk about propaganda you know
propaganda is just painting someone in a
bias light you know you could have a a
politician and somebody could spray
paint horns on them and suddenly think
by a picture alone you think that
person's bad or somebody this
Association just takes over yeah the
same picture could have a Halo drawn
over it in Sun raay and now they look
like a savior so Satan's doing that with
God he's putting God in the stories and
in Christ and using all the same
character traits but painting him in a
wrong light you know you Satan is um
he's a master at Deception a lot of
things he spoke was truth right but it's
that 10% error that 1% error 1% error is
not truth no and so if he can paint God
in a bad way over time repetition
watching these things over and over and
over will begin to change our minds we
subscribe to that right that's right so
Jesus you know he he was a powerful
Storyteller in Matthew 13:34 it says all
these things spake Jesus unto the
multitudes in Parables and without a
parable spake he not unto them cuz
stories are powerful when we want to
teach our child to not tell lies it's a
lot more powerful to tell the story of
the sheep the boy who cried wolf that's
right because there's a lesson wrapped
up in that and and the story sticks with
a kid Just Like Music very power you're
using the imagination in a productive
manner that's right that leads them to
light there's nothing wrong with
imagination if it's used the proper way
so Satan knows this he's using the same
method he always takes what God does and
he perverts it so Satan is saying hey
you tell stories I can tell stories too
and I have a million dooll budget with
all these special effects and it's
hypnotic to people they're drawn to it
when they see that trailer they'll
they'll line up people aren't lining up
to get into church no they're not but
they're camping to see the next movie
right right and Satan's not going to let
that type of opportunity just go by he's
got an agenda and so a question we get
asked a lot is do we think all these
Hollywood actors and directors are just
in a smoke filed room saying like how
can we deceive the Christians no we
don't believe that but we believe that
you're you're inspired by someone if
you're walking with God if you're asking
God to inspire you then you will be
inspired by him but if you're not and
you're walking in the things of the
world that's a perfect opportunity for
Satan to give you you know visions and
scripts and all that dreams and
abilities that you didn't have otherwise
and that's why they often use
celebrities to package the devil's
messages yeah beautiful people and a lot
of these people will openly tell you uh
James Cameron and the lady that wrote
Harry Potter they're like hey this came
from a dream I wrote it down and now
they're the bestselling movies of all
time the actors will say the same things
like that wasn't me out there like when
I go on the set something else takes
over and some of them will go as far as
to say that they pray to spirits and
they Channel and all that and some do it
intentionally yeah I did uh see a news
uh re about a young man who's on
snowfall okay and it's I think a
subscription based uh program and he
plays a drug dealer and he said that he
had come to a block in his process and
that he went in the corner and said you
know Satan help me and that he did so
and that it was like a one take and he
was able to get through it and it was
convincing and compelling but it came
with some repercussions and that was
that he kept having demonic dreams such
that he had to call his mother and say
mama pray for me and you talked about
that intercessory prayer that's right
and so it does it creeps in I think a
lot of people do this unaware you know
they call it method acting and things
like that but just some examples I want
to give some examples of of how this
media affects all groups of people
because you might say well I don't watch
all that dark stuff I just watch I like
the Matrix you know a sci-fi movie it
was one of my favorite movies of all the
time but in the movie The the main
antagonist are three beings that talk
alike look alike sound alike finish each
other's sentences who does that make you
think of the Trinity the godhead yeah so
the godhead or the Trinity being the
villain and they are actually known as
the secret police so there what what
happens in the movie is he's told by
someone else Lucifer told Adam and Eve
that this world you're in is is not the
real world that you can eat this fruit
and have your eyes open the same thing
happens in this movie Morpheus who is
wearing a a a long trench coat that has
scales all over it you know it's very
symbolic and he offers him he says hey I
can open your eyes if you take the red
pill which is very symbolic of the Apple
that Adam and Eve ate from you know we
don't know if it was an apple but it's
often portrayed that way or he says or
you can take the blue pill which blue
represents the Law he says you can take
the blue pill and stay in la la land or
you can take this red pill have your
eyes open and see the truth and so in
the scene Neo the main character he
decides and he takes the red pill and as
he takes the pill the camera goes back
to Morpheus and he gets this evil grin
and there's lightning and thunder behind
him just as if you know God saw this and
was angry and so the devil is basically
just planted something in your mind so
subtly and you just think it's
entertainment yep entertainment and and
sometimes even people associate it in a
different way they're like well this is
kind of like waking up to secret
societies or something but you have to
just step back and look at all the
imagery there's so much tied into it and
the the directors openly said yes it is
a gnostic movie so they agreed and so
when Morpheus takes Neo and he's he's
kind of giv him a tour of this world
that he's been living in he's saying
look everything's black and white
everything's rules and everything is you
know based on this system but that's our
enemy and so they walk everything's so
symbolic they walk against the traffic
of people that are wearing just black
and white going across them they're
going against the grain and then
Morpheus says teachers lawyers
Carpenters these are our enemies name
one person who was a teacher a lawyer
and a carpenter Jesus Jesus Christ so
there is definitely an attack you see
that Morpheus is dressed like the
serpent offering the the ability to have
your eyes open and then walking against
rules and telling you that teachers
lawyers and Carpenters are the enemy and
so in the end of the movie Neo ends up
having a conversation with the Matrix or
the the whole system and he's saying
you're afraid of us and you you put us
in this system full of rules but I'm
going to tell people of a world without
rules and without you and this is what
we're being
and and you just think about in the last
days we're going to be in a world of
lawlessness and yeah our flesh we don't
like rules we think like oh you're
telling me what I can and can't do but
imagine a world with no rules
realistically so that reminds me of the
it's basically like a Gnostic Gospel
that they're promoting and I remember
there was a movie called I believe Harry
Truman and it was pretty clear you know
oh Truman Show Truman Show that's what
it was same thing yeah he was put in
this perfect world and he was even being
watched by the producer in the sky who
called himself the Creator he said I'm
the creator of a TV show and when he
realizes that he's on this set he opens
up the door and it's complete darkness
and the Creator speaks to him and says
I've been watching you your whole life
I've I've put you in a perfect world
there's nothing but pain and misery out
there but he's on a reality show and
everybody's watching and they're on the
edge of their seat to see what kind of
decision he makes and he decides to walk
out that to that utter darkness and the
whole watching World cheers what message
is that giving the Watcher they're
saying I don't want to be in a perfect
world I want to go out there where all
the pain and the misery is and walk away
and turn my back on the Creator right
because there's something secret out
there that I need to know that's right
and and so that was you know that was
Lucifer's argument in the garden hey you
can go out of this Garden but there was
it was death and thorns and all these
things out there so do they also use
signs and symbols that are you know
familiar to us Christians oh yeah yeah
and and Satan's so subtle man he loves
to make it look like one thing because
that's how propaganda works it's it's
packaged in a pretty little package that
you can agree with it's about a
counterfeit basically yeah like oh this
movie is about creativity or it's about
you know racial Justice or whatever it
is to get your heartstrings attached to
it and so another movie would be Star
Wars you know some people would say I
don't watch that dark stuff I like Star
Wars where it's good versus evil it's
light versus dark but what if that's
just the propaganda what if it's the the
villain actually has all these character
traits of Christ and the good guy
actually has more in common with Satan
so you look at somebody like Darth Vader
they call him Lord voder a father
they're calling him Lord father thought
about that yes and his outfit he's
literally wearing something very similar
to what the high priest would wear and
his the epod yeah and he's wearing the
chest plate with these colored buttons
on it and if that sounds sounds like a
stretch to people then when you go to
the the conventions they actually bring
the outfit that was on the movie and
when you get a close-up look of the
outfit between those buttons is Hebrew
writing now why would an alien from a
far distant Galaxy long long ago have
Hebrew written in between his buttons on
his chest plate good point um his army
is military no he's the ruler of an
Empire and an Empire is is a whole
system controlled by one person and when
you look at his military it's all in
perfect order the Storm Troopers are all
dressed in perfect white but then your
side and the mine Associates that with
light and goodness yeah Purity and all
that and Order and when you watch the
movies and if you look at the Wikipedia
here it says that Anakin which is Darth
Vader when he was younger he is the
prophesied chosen one so we're talking
about Jesus and right we're talking
about prophecy now so he was the chosen
one that was prophesied the father Lord
V with the ephod and they call him Lord
so in the comic and in one of the movies
he somebody's watching him fight and
they're like oh the force is strong with
this one who was his father and the
mother answers and said there was no
father I can't explain it I was just
pregnant and here he is so he literally
was born unto maybe not a virgin but had
no father no earthly father Earthly
father right how can we look at this as
as Darth Vader is Satan there's no way
to look at it that way mhm so what about
the good guy well his name is Luke which
means light which could be good but we
know that Lucifer was also the
lightbearer and he is over the Rebellion
the good guys are actually called the
rebellion and they're all chaotic and
they're going against the empire they're
resisting the Empire so it's a Mis
portrayal of Jesus anyway because he
didn't come when he came he didn't come
to start a revolution right a peacemaker
and so it all this gets tied in these
are more like adult movies but it it
goes into a lot of children's films and
and the message is just so different
it's like think about the movie Frozen
so there's a song a very famous song in
the movie called Let It Go you don't
want to hear me sing it but I know what
you're talking about and it'll be stuck
in your head all day yeah because those
those songs are very powerful they're
addictive they get stuck in your head
and you see little girls singing this
parents clapping oh that's so good but
in the lyrics She says no right no wrong
no rules for me I'm free so this reminds
me of yoga uh it was very much open your
heart free your heart follow your heart
empty your mind yeah wherever we heard
follow your heart that's Disney's famous
slogan in almost every movie is follow
your heart they even have you know
icecapades and it's called the follow
your heart tour or whatever so that's
Disney's main focus is follow your heart
even though the Bible says your heart is
deceitful above all things and
desperately wicked who can who can know
it you can't trust your heart because
your heart is emotions it's selfish it's
self- serving until it's been delivered
and opened unto the Lord that's right
and and it goes like this I mean it's a
roller coaster your heart you could be
feeling like oh I love this person and
the next day like I can't stand that
person you can't trust your heart so to
follow your heart is is a satanic
message and then the breaking of the
rules in so many movies um have you ever
seen Aladdin growing up uh yeah so think
about this in a we have to look at
everything through the lens of the Bible
when we're when we're watching things
all these princess movies if we are to
be married to the Prince of Peace we're
the bride of Christ right that's right
what does that make us if we're M if
we're the Bride of a prince what does
that make us symbolically well chosen
holy and a princess princess so you have
all these movies about these princesses
and in Aladdin movie she was supposed to
marry the prince her her father's the
king our father's the king that's right
and he wanted his princess daughter to
marry the prince but in comes this thief
Aladdin who's literally a thief a poor
man and he steals an apple and he gives
it to her and he sings a song and he
says I can open your eyes this is
exactly Genesis right giving her the
fruit saying I can open your eyes and I
can take you to a whole new world where
no one to tell us no or where to go
always taking you to a world with no
rules Peter Pan same thing you think
about your pre-teen daughter up in her
room and some boy flies up there and
says hey I want to take you to never
Neverland this is incredible The Lost
Boys where there's no rules the only
thing is is you can't ever come
back and that's also a lie because I've
seen repeatedly people testify who have
come on a wolf and sheep's clothing and
they were in the abyss of darkness God's
hand is never T retracted from you until
you grieve the Holy Spirit and if he can
pull those people out he could pull
anyone out there who's struggling yes
and I've been down that road as well
there was a a movie called Wreck-It
Ralph and it was about a game system and
the main character was a carpenter named
Felix oh my goodness who's the good guy
and he I fell for it I I totally Miss I
did see it I saw it and I liked it but
think about it he's the good guy of
niceand right what a fairy tale way of
talking about heaven and all of them
live in the penthouse like none of the
floors of that building are occupied
except the top floor and in the
beginning they show how Ralph the bad
guy was cast out of nice land into the
city dump which Jesus used that as a
metaphor with um gehenna and so the it's
this whole Sympathy for the Devil thing
because Ralph is telling people you know
I was created this way the Creator made
me a bad guy but I wish I was a good guy
and so he starts going to these meetings
of other bad guys including Satan is in
that group pops up in that group yeah I
remember that and and they're saying
whoa don't mess with the system this is
how you were created you were born this
way is the new term and even though
you'd never seen him interacting with
Satan he was familiar with him oh hi
Satan it was very casual nonchalant and
so Ralph has an agenda he wants to get
this golden medal because he says if I
can get that golden medal I can be like
Felix so we know that Satan said I can
be like the most high I can do it in My
Own Strength I don't need you or your
law so as he's chasing this metal that
makes him like the carpenter the good
guy Carpenter he ends up going to a
place called Candy Land and the the
metal is hanging in a tree and he meets
a girl at the tree Eve you have to think
of this whole thing you have to look at
the lens of the Bible so Satan is
literally interacting with a woman at
the tree and she takes the metal and
when she takes it she glitches for the
first time yeah so now sin has been
introduced into this perfect game world
and they're being told don't let the
creator of the game see that you're
glitching because if he sees you
glitching they'll unplug the game just
like you know this is this is really
true in a sense we know that God has to
cleanse the Earth of sin he has to start
it over and make a perfect world again
but they're painting it in the light
that this king candy guy is a villain
and that you don't want the Creator to
see you're glitched out because he's
going to wipe out the whole system you
and I are both Testaments that that's
not true we were glitching so to speak
and God reached in and got us but that's
not how this movie ends it doesn't say
we can fix that glitch instead the
lesson is embrace your glitch because
the girl swears that she'll never glitch
again and as she's racing she has to win
the race so she uses the glitch to her
advantage and crosses the Finish Line
ahead of everybody so cheating cheating
using sin as a way to win and then she
becomes the most picked player of the
game so we're starting to wind down give
me another example okay another example
would be a lot of the comic movies a lot
of people are getting into the comic
movies DC Marvel all this stuff Avengers
yeah it's really hot right now yeah but
Batman is one that people kind of look
at well you know he's he's about Justice
and bringing you know trying to make
things right and it's a classic it's
been around since my father's time yeah
one interesting thing just it's kind of
a visual thing but a long time ago he
used to wear like blue and gray it was
very campy and colorful and all that and
even the the jingle to it was like da
and he had a little guy with him Robin
it it seemed innocent right and you you
watch the evolution of where it's come
today to now he's The Dark Knight and
literally there's not a color on him
even his logo used to be yellow and now
it's black or gray so just the imagery
alone is getting darker and darker and
darker and I thought Batman was based
off of a bat right but the artist who
created him said no Batman is based off
of a demon and so you look and you see
the comic books and they're named birth
of the demon Batman son of the demon
Batman tales of the demon so Batman is
literally a demon that we have made a
hero he's glorified and and the people
that he goes against are are oftentimes
have a lot of character traits of Christ
uh and Batman Returns the penguin was
born on Christmas Day put into a basket
in a river and when he when he grows up
oh he he died 33 years later oh wow I I
did this all of this I'm it just went
right over my head I didn't even think
about it yeah we've all been tricked
because we're not expecting to the enemy
to attack us so subtly yeah and so you
know with Marvel like you mentioned the
Avengers all these superheroes the the
comic book creators themselves this is
not just me I'm not just some religious
at saying all this stuff's evil it's
coming from their own mouths they will
tell you Batman is Hades Aquaman is Zeus
Hermes you know all these people Thor
these are Greek and Roman and pagan gods
myology being glorified right repackaged
and turned into superheroes and this is
what they're saying themselves right and
so when you look at the Bible and and
think about where the Israelites kept
getting tripped up by all these pagan
gods and and God saying don't even
mention their names and yet we're
glorifying the name
Thor and so you think of a movie like
Avengers where all over the over time
now Satan is patient too he's getting
you sucked in the first movie oh it
wasn't that bad the second movie was a
little maybe there was some iffy things
in there by the third movie you're
already so addicted to it you're wearing
the t-shirts you're talking about it
you're telling people oh you got to see
it exactly and you're taking other
people so we're evangelizing people to
this thing we're witnessing on behalf of
the wrong Doctrine and so the The
Avengers movie was all about leading up
to endgame which was we're going to
fight Thanos and if you look at the
character traits of Thanos is an
immortal all powerful God who sits on a
throne in a spaceship called The
Sanctuary no way and he's coming to
Earth to snap his fingers and Destroy
half a Humanity separating the sheep
from the goats yeah this is literally a
like every aspect of him is Christ who's
sitting in the sanctuary and he will
come to separate the sheep from the
goats the wheat from the tears and in
the movie all these pagan gods Roman
gods mutants they come together they put
aside their differences and say we have
to fight to defend Earth and they come
together the Creator the true creator
that's right they you know I don't think
it's an an accident that they named it
endgame we are literally in the end
times right but I want to turn our
attention to who is Mikey today and how
is he using his talents I just thank God
for giving me eyes to see because even
as a new Christian I remember rejecting
this message I would hear people say oh
Harry Potter is pushing witchcraft I'm
like it's a kid's show let these kids
imagine I was so blinded you know it
says that the God of this world has
blinded us but if we're really seeking
for truth we can pray to God and ask for
spiritual discernment and in an instant
he knocked those scales off my eyes just
like Saul on the road to Damascus I
remember it stood me up out of my seat
December 2011 and I was just like I can
see it all for the way it is M and it's
a gift from God discernment is but we
have to desire that we have to desire if
it's if it makes me have to put away
everything that I've ever loved I just
want truth he will answer that prayer
what's beautiful about Christ is that he
wants to cleans the temple so that he
can be dwelling in Us by us and through
us and it's just beautiful to see how he
has delivered you that's right Psalm
1013 says I will set nothing Wicked
before my eyes you know some people
think think that if I don't do it if I'm
not doing it then it's not bad but
really we should not be entertaining
ourselves with witchcraft Heroes that
are literally Greek and Pagan Roman gods
so I just challenge people ask for
discernment look at this template that
I've shown and see if you see this
repetitious pattern and if you see it
don't entertain your minds with this
stuff thank you so much this is just
great
information the Bible compels us to
examine ourselves and work out our
salvation with fear and trembling in the
words of the psalmist I will set nothing
Wicked before my eyes and job said I
have made a covenant with my eyes we
would do well to do the same Remember
Everything That Glitters Is really not
gold if there is Temptation before your
eyes ask for the spirit of discernment
and ask the Lord to be with you until
the next time this has been a wolf in
sheep's clothing
[Music]
[Applause]